[Music]
clark county says we hit a positive
milestone today with 70 percent of
people getting at least one coveted
vaccine shot in fact that was the very
first vaccine goal they set before they
loosened some of the rules so let's take
a look at the numbers for today clark
county is reporting
123 cases per 100 000 people now our
mass mandate is tied to getting this
number to 100 cases also clark county
reporting a drop in test positivity
another positive sign it's at eight
point two percent today in fact it was
at eight point four percent on friday
and let's take a look now the
vaccinations fifty four point six
percent of the county these are now
fully vaccinated numbers that's compared
to the partial number we gave you just a
moment ago now we have compiled all of
your covet information in one place
here's an easy way to get there point
your cell phone camera at this qr code
on your screen then click on the link
that pops up and it'll take you to
8newsnow.com for a number of helpful
resources